we could talk about this all the mini
cops that are getting exposed
on twitter oh the the a little tiny
little tiny boy cops that make sense
toddler cops man that was that guy who
told me i'm not here to joke dude he
he was built like a like a
like a a small italian like craft maker
like he was
maybe five six slick back hair
and couldn't be more than 110 dude
the gear the gears like weighing them
down oh bro
his yeah his belt looked like it didn't
fit like he he was built like um
like a like a cardboard cutout of john
cena that like you would stand next to
at a [ __ ] carnival or some [ __ ] he
was so tiny
i was like bro i don't i'm like you
should learn to laugh man
yeah exactly maybe some things should be
joked about
bro the the one my favorite on twitter
is the is the tiny cop with the um
he had hand sanitizer on his waist
no way like he's gonna finish [ __ ]
hitting somebody
with a baton and then walk away just
right yeah
give his baton a hand job real quick
he's got to make sure you
got to make sure you sanitize clean the
clean the blood off this bad boy
oh i wasn't even thinking about it like
that
that's [ __ ] nice you're getting hit
by one of those [ __ ] that
oh yeah man oh yeah
yeah and you see all these wounds from
the rubber bullets like these people
with
chunks out of their [ __ ] forehead
it's [ __ ] up dude
oh my god you see a video of the one in
like philly or pittsburgh or whatever of
the
dudes shooting tear gas into the into
the protesters that don't have anywhere
to go like
pittsburgh yeah yeah and they're trapped
up against the wall oh no no i was
thinking
they can't like where they're like oh
yeah yeah that's pittsburgh yeah and
they're like on the side of the
it's like a highway yeah there's like a
wall and they're on a sidewalk and just
shooting tear gas into it and all the
people are like trying to climb up the
wall but oh yeah they can like get out
letting it sing man that [ __ ] clip of
lapd doing the little [ __ ] drive-by
oh yeah just pull up on the teenagers
crazy man crazy there's this other clip
where this cop tried to kneel with
people
his [ __ ] sergeant yanked him up he
was like don't do that [ __ ]
and he tried to do it again and he
yanked him up he was like don't do that
yeah yeah so there was the
the clip of the national guard kneeling
that was pretty cool yeah
well the thing is dude national guard is
like weekend warriors
as far as i know uh and a lot of how
well so if you look like a lot of them
are young and a lot of people join
national guard because they need
um scholarship to go to school so a lot
of them join to be part-time
and when you're national guard you i
think
you're if you're part-time national
guard you only do one weekend a month
and two weeks in the summer and then
obviously if a situation like this
arises you have to you have to report in
but
you know they're mostly um at least if
you're part-time
your your duty is is very selective
so i think that's got to be [ __ ]
weird too if you're in the national
guard and you're called into a situation
like this and you're like [ __ ]
20 yeah and you're like ah i didn't and
all of a sudden you're like driving a
tank
yeah hollywood yeah and you're like look
you see that
you know the [ __ ] like decked out
army cars and
like on hollywood boulevard it's like
what the [ __ ] is happening
so crazy dude and dude did you watch
trump's speech
um which one the one where he like did
the
did the bible [ __ ] afterwards no where
he was just like
god on my [ __ ] head it was wild dude
got on my phone
nerves man he's like yeah i just told
all the all the um
governors like if you don't use
excessive force here you're
you're weak and just like i i
will not be afraid to bring in the
military at any point and just solve the
problem for you
if this is it's just violent just he's
like he's like just stop
put a stop to it end it yeah it just did
just distill everything down to
yeah to those five words just
[ __ ] put a stop to it that's uh it's
just like gross
that's just some police state [ __ ]
right there man it's just like i don't i
don't like what you guys are saying shut
the [ __ ] up
that's that's that's uncomfortable bro
yeah it was rough
and then it just it just someone linked
me that uh
clip of him through saying the [ __ ]
about the bible
oh yeah it's a book or it's a bible
no he's like what what's your favorite
part of the bible he's like i just
you know so i don't i don't like to
discuss that it's so
personal and uh but anything you know do
you like the old testament you like the
new he's like i like them both
the same you know and i don't want to
get into like the specifics i'm just
saying they're really important to me
and
it's like it's personal like strippers
got john 3 16 and they're [ __ ]
instagram dude get the [ __ ] out of here
man
get the [ __ ] out of here man yeah i just
you know i just love everything yeah
it's just every verse how could you even
compare them you know there's so they're
all
you read the next verse and the next one
and they're all so good it's like how do
you even
talking like dudes in utah trying to
hook up with mormon girls but they're
not mormons
exactly yeah man i like it all dude
it's all good man yeah dude how do you
even pick there's so many good ones
yeah bible i read it every night
every single night i've been through it
five six
i don't times pick i'd even pick i mean
so many good lessons thou shall not
you